based on what we learned in the last
video let's see if we can name these two
molecules here so let's start with this
blue one so the first thing we notice it
is an alkene it has a double bond right
there so we can write from the get-go
right that it's going to end with n N
and then we need to figure out what the
longest carbon chain is and it looks
like it's this one here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
carbons so it's going to be HEPT it's
going to be kept as our prefix on the
alkene it's going to be let me write it
out a little bit further to the left
HEPT
and then we have to figure out where the
double bond is and we always want to
start numbering our carbons from the
direction that bumps into the double
bond first and so the double bond is
closer to this end of the chain than
that ends we're going to start numbering
here so 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and so the double
bond starts on the 3 carbon so it is
HEPT it is HEPT 3e
and we also have a functional group we
have a methyl group sitting on the
number 4 carbon so it is 4 it is 4
methyl 4 methyl HEPT 3 n which is
correct but we still haven't considered
what what's going on on either side of
the double bond whether the higher
priority functional group is or whether
they're closer to each other on both
sides of the double bond or whether
they're farther away from each other
and to do that we first have to identify
the higher priority group on each side
of the double bond so on the right side
of the double bond let me circle it in
magenta on each side so on the right
side of the double bond we only have one
functional group right over here you
could view this as an ethyl group that's
pretty obvious there is no other
functional group bonded to the carbon
there's only a hydrogen over here now on
the left side it's a little bit less
obvious we have two functional groups
from the point of view of this carbon
you have the methyl that we already
pointed out and you also have these 3
carbons right over here you could view
that as a propyl group and what we need
to do to identify the highest priority
group is to use the cahn-ingold-prelog
namings or priority scheme that we
learned several videos ago
and there you literally go from this
carbon you look at the you look at what
it's bonded to and if this carbon and
you compare the atomic numbers but in
both cases it's a carbon to a carbon
this is a carbon to a carbon so they're
atomic numbers are the same so then you
go one bond further away and you say
which one is bonded to a higher atomic
number atom this carbon bonds to a
carbon which is a higher atomic number
this carbon only bonds to three
hydrogen's this one does two hydrogens
and one carbon because it's bonded to
another carbon it takes priority
this propyl group is a higher priority
functional group so now when we're
trying to decide whether it is entgegen
or zusammen
we look at these two groups and we see
that they are sitting on the same side
of the double bond they're both above
the carbons they are closer to each
other so this is this molecule is
zusammen or if we were doing which is on
some levels you can think of the same
thing as sis but sis and trans stop
supplying when you start having more
than two functional groups in this case
we have three so we would call this we
would call this Z Z for methyl HEPT
3 and that's because the higher priority
functional groups are on the same side
of the double bond now let's do this one
over here and I someone pointed out
rightly that I misspelled zusammen
in the last video it's actually spelled
like this zusammen
I had spelt it with two S's and one M I
guess you can forgive me I don't speak
German but anyway thought I would point
that out now let's try to let's try to
label this thing right over here so the
first thing this once again is an alkene
let's identify the longest carbon chain
here so it looks like 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
carbons double bonds are closer to the
left-hand side so we'll start numbering
here 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so just the main
chain is acht make sure I have some
space here it is acht 3 acht 3 N and
then we have some well we have one
functional group sitting off of the main
chain
we have this bromine we have this
bromine sitting right over there on the
third carbon so we would call this three
bromo three bromo acht three een and now
we have to figure out is it ink again or
zusammen
so if we look on the carbon on the right
hand side it's pretty obvious that this
is the only functional group we just
have a hydrogen there so let me circle
it in the magenta just like that and
then on the left hand side we have two
functional groups we have this broom we
could view this as a bromo or we have a
bromine sitting right there and then we
have this propyl group and because this
propyl group is bigger you might be
tempted to say it takes higher priority
but remember in the con Engle Ingold
prelog system you give higher priority
to the atom that has a higher atomic
number bromine has an atomic number of
35 carbon has an atomic number of only
six so bromine is actually higher
priority so this is the higher priority
functional group right over here so now
for deciding whether it's n kagan or
zusammen we see that our higher priority
groups are apart they're on opposite
sides of the double bond this one is on
top this one is below we are apart so
this is entgegen
and again or we would write e this is e
3 bromo acht 3 E and E is 4 just as a
bit of a refresher it's 4 entgegen a
word that I enjoy saying and gig in
there you go